كثفت روسيا هجماتها على البنيه التحتيه
العسكريه للقواعد الجويه
الاوكرانيه احدثها اعلان موسكو استهداف
مطار في مقاطعه كيف بسلاح عالي الدقه
وتاكيدها اصابه جميع الاهداف المحدده
وبحسب وزاره الدفاع الروسيه فان الضربه
شملت ايضا تدمير محطه رادار لكشف الاهداف
الجويه وتوجيه الطائرات المقاتله واستهداف
انظمه الصواريخ المضاده للطائرات بالقرب
من مدينه زابروجيا ويبدو واضحا ان الضربات
تستهدف ادارات ومواقع قواعد سلاح الجو في
اوكرانيا التي تنقسم الى ثلاث مناطق
رئيسيه مقر قياده سلاح الجو وتتبع ضمن
الدائره الاداريه المباشره له اربع مطارات
عسكريه قياده المنطقه الجنوبيه في سلاح
الجو وتتبع لها ثلاثه مطارات عسكريه خرج
احدها وهو مطار وقاعده بلبيك في
سيفاستوبول عن سيطره اوكرانيا بضم روسيا
شبه جزيره القرم قياده المنطقه الغربيه في
سلاح الجو الاوكراني ويتبع لها مطاران
عسكريان ومع تسارع الخطوات التي يمكن ان
تفضي لحصول اوكرانيا على مقاتلات اف 16
بموافقه دول على تقديم طرازات غير حديثه
منها الى كيف وبدء تدريب طيارين اوكرانيين
تسارعت الضربات لكن الاستهداف الاحدث بحسب
خبراء لا يتعلق فقط باخراج مطارات عسكريه
من الخدمه بل بمحاوله تعطيل ما يمكن ان
يكون قواعد توجيه للطائرات المسيره التي
باتت السلاح الاوكرانيه الاكثر استخداما
في العمق الروسي
ضربات تؤدي الى ايقاف حركه مطارات العاصمه
موسكو ولو انها لم تصب هذه المنشات كما
باتت تشكل تهديدا لمواقع صناعيه روسيه كما
يحدث في استهداف كالوجا اكثر من مره
وباضافة
قد تشير لتبدل في تكتيكات الهجوم المضاد
الاوكراني الذي يتعثر عند خطوط التماس بين
الجيشين لكنه يحقق نقاطا لصالح كيف في
الاستهدافات غير
التقليديه